>>> IF YOU HAVEN'T READ THIS,
YOU NEED TO.
A DEEP DIVE IN "THE NEW YORKER"
PAINT AGO STUNNING PORTRAIT OF
ELON MUSK.
STUNNING IN MULTIPLE WAYS.
THE FOCUS ON THE BILLIONAIRE'S
GROWING INFLUENCE IN THE WAR ON
UKRAINE AND THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
AT LARGE.
ACCORDING TO THE NEW REPORT, ON
A CALL WITH PENTAGON OFFICIALS
ABOUT HIS COMPANY'S
SATELLITE-BASED INTERNET THAT
UKRAINIAN TROOPS HAVE BEEN
RELYING ON IN THE BATTLEFIELD,
HE MENTIONED HE HAD A
CONVERSATION.
HE SPOKE TO RUSSIAN PRESIDENT
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
HE PREVIOUSLY DENIED IT.
THE FORMER UNDERSECRETARY FOR
DEFENSE OF POLICY TOLD THE
MAGAZINE THAT MUSK SAID HE SPOKE
TO THE RUSSIAN PRESIDENT AT THE
SAME TIME U.S. DEFENSE OFFICIALS
WERE WORRIED HE MAY PULL
STARLINK OUT OF UKRAINE, THE
UNDERSECRETARY TOLD THE REPORTER
THE JOURNALIST WHO WROTE THIS
RONAN FARROW THAT THEY WERE
ANXIOUS THEY MIGHT SEE HIS
COMPANY'S INVOLVEMENT INABLE THE
WAR TO PROLONG ON UKRAINE.
>> FARROW REPORTED THAT MUSK'S
INFLUENCE WITHIN THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT IS WIDESPREAD AND
THAT OVER THE LAST TWO DECADES,
QUOTE, MUSK SOUGHT OUT BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES IN CRUCIAL AREAS,
AFTER DECADES OF PRIVATIZATION,
THE STATE HAS RECEDED.
THE GOVERNMENT IS RELIANT ON HIM
BUT STRUGGLES TO RESPOND TO HIS
RISK TAKING, BRINKSMANSHIP.
"THE NEW YORKER" CONTRIBUTING
RIGHTER RONAN FARROW JOINS US
NOW ON HIS LATEST ARTICLE.
ELON MUSK SHADOW RULE, HO HOW
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT CAME TO RELY
ON THE TECH BILLIONAIRE AND IS
D
STRUGGLING TO REIN HIM IN.
THERE IS A LINE HERE WHERE YOU
ARE, YOU KNOW, TRYING TO GET
SOME QUESTIONS FROM THE PENTAGON
ABOUT EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AND
THE SPOKESMAN SAYS THAT -- AND
THIS IS A QUOTE HERE -- WE'LL
TALK TO YOU IF ELON WANTS US TO.
THERE IS A DEGREE OF DEFERENCE
HERE FROM THE PENTAGON?
>> THAT'S A SMALL MANIFESTATION
OF THE BALANCE OF POWER WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT BETWEEN THE
PRIVATE INDIVIDUAL, WHO IS SO
WEALTHY AND POWERFUL IN
DIFFERENT FIELDS, AND THE
GOVERNMENT, THE ACTUAL STATE.
THAT IS A COMPLICATED DYNAMIC
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT HAS SOME
PROSE.
HE HAS ADVANCED VARIOUS FIELDS
IN MEANINGFUL WAYS.
THERE IS A REASON U.S.
GOVERNMENT IS SO RELIANT ON HIM
IN ALL OF THESE WAYS.
AT THE SAME TIME, HE IS SOMEONE
WHO HAS BEHAVED ERRATICALLY AND
THE FACT THAT WE'RE GETTING THAT
KIND OF A COMMUNICATION FROM THE
GOVERNMENT AS JOURNALISTS, LIKE
WE'LL GO THROUGH THIS PRIVATE
INDIVIDUAL, THAT'S PRETTY
UNUSUAL AND IT IS A SMALL BUT
SIGNIFICANT SIGNED OF HOW
BEHOLDEN THEY ARE.
>> ONE THING I THOUGHT WAS
INTERESTING IS HOW YOU MY LIGHT
IN THE PIECE, NATIONAL SECURITY
OFFICIALS I SPOKE WITH, MEANING
YOU, HAD A WIDE RANGE OF VIEWS
ON THE GOVERNMENT'S BALANCE OF
POWER WITH MUSK.
A SUPPORTER IS GENERAL MILLEY
WHO SPOKE GLOWINGLY ABOUT HIM?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THE FRAMEWORK FOR SEVERAL OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH PEOPLE
WHO WERE SO SUPPORTIVE OF HIM
WAS THAT ALL OF THE
CONVERSATIONS IN ADVANCE AND
WITH THEIR TEAMS WERE ABOUT,
OKAY, BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE ARE MAKING CLEAR TO ELON WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF HIM.
YOU GET A GLIMPSE INTO THE
TEXTURE OF THE RELATIONSHIPS.
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH
THOSE KINDS OF WARM
RELATIONSHIPS, OBVIOUSLY,
BETWEEN A PRIVATE INDIVIDUAL AND
SIGNIFICANT GOVERNMENT
LEADERSHIP.
EVEN IN THE CONTEXT OF A
MILITARY CONTRACTOR
RELATIONSHIP.
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING MORE AND
DIFFERENT.
I TALKED TO A LOT OF HISTORIANS
TO GET A SENSE HOW NEW THIS IS,
THE FACT THAT WE CAN ONLY PUT
CREW INTO SPACE THAT NASA HAS TO
GO THROUGH ELON MUSK AND NO ONE
ELSE.
THE ONLY ALTERNATIVE RIGHT NOW
AT THIS MOMENT, PROBABLY FOR THE
NEXT YEAR, IS SENDING PEOPLE UP
VIA RUSSIAN LAUNCHES.
THE FACT THAT IF WE WANT TO
ADVANCE GREEN ENERGY POLICIES
AROUND ELECTRIC VEHICLES, WE GOT
TO GO THROUGH ELON AND HIS
CHARGING STATIONS.
HISTORIAN SAYS THAT IS A NEW
EXTREME AND NEWLY POLITICAL
DIMENSION TO THIS PRIVATE POWER.
>> SPECIFICALLY ON RUSSIA'S WAR
IN UKRAINE, I THINK THE MOST
OBVIOUS EXAMPLE FOR MOST PEOPLE
AT HOME IS WHEN HE DECIDED TO
END THE INTERNET SERVICE THROUGH
STARLINK, HE EXCLUSIVELY OFFERS
TO THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY, AND
THAT'S HOW THEY COMMUNICATE,
OBVIOUSLY.
HE THEN REVERSED IT THAT.
BEMOANED THE COST.
BUT IS THE PENTAGON, IS THE
GOVERNMENT ATTEMPTING TO UNRAVEL
THIS AT ALL NOW THAT EVERYONE
KNOWS THE DEPENDENCE?
>> TWO THINGS HAPPENED.
ONE IS AT THE END OF THIS STORY,
ONE OF THE MANY STORIES IN THIS
PRO VIAL, A STANDOFF OVER
INTERNET ACCESS IN UKRAINE.
IT APPEARS HE WAS TALKING TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN, TELLING MULTIPLE
PEOPLE THAT AT THE TIME, AS YOU
POINT OUT HE SINCE TRIED TO DENY
THAT, AND THEN HE WAS CURTAILING
ACCESS SPECIFICALLY IN AREAS
THAT RUSSIA WAS CONTESTING.
AT THE END OF THAT, ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAPPENED WAS THE
PENTAGON DID PAY UP.
THEY SAID, YOU KNOW, WE ARE
GOING TO GET A DEAL IN PLACE TO
MAKE SURE THIS DOESN'T SHUT OFF
ENTIRELY.
BUT THE OTHER THING THAT
HAPPENED IS PEOPLE ON THE GROUND
IN UKRAINE, PEOPLE ON THE FRONT
LINES REMAINED SPOOKED, RIGHT?
>> RIGHT.
>> WE BOUGHT HIS SERVICES.
APPARENTLY AT A VERY, YOU KNOW,
GENEROUS RATE.
THIS IS THE SITUATION WHERE
METAPHORICALLY HE HAD THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT AND THE UKRAINIANS AT
GUNPOINT.
AND TO THIS DAY, THEY DO FEAR
THAT HE IS GOING TO CURTAIL
SERVICE MORE.
SO VERY HARD TO GET PEOPLE TO
TALK IN THAT CONTEXT.
I AM GLAD THAT SOME DID.
>> ONCE YOU GET INTO THE SORT OF
MIDDLE OF THE PIECE, YOU BACK
INTO HIS LIFE AND YOU GO TO HIS
CHILDHOOD, HIS FIRST MARRIAGE,
LOSING HIS FIRST CHILD, ALL OF
THE THINGS THAT CREATED THE MUSK
THAT WE KNOW.
CAN YOU SPEAK ABOUT THE MUSK
THAT WE KNOW NOW VIA X, FORMERLY
TWITTER, AND YOU TALK AT THE END
ABOUT HIM TAKING ON A.I. AND THE
WAY THAT WE HAVE SEEN HIM
OPERATE AND CONDUCT HIMSELF WITH
TWITTER AND NOW A.I. BECAUSE YOU
QUOTE SAL
M SALT MAN SAY
WANTS THE WORLD TO BE SAVED BUT
ONLY IF HE CAN BE THE ONE TO
SAVE IT.
>> THIS WAS A COMMON SENTIMENT
AMONGST ELON MUSK'S PEERS.
HE DOES THIS SIGNIFICANT WORK
THAT AT TIMES, IN MY MIND, IT'S
A NET POSITIVE FOR ALL OF US.
EVEN IN SOME OF THESE SPACES
WHERE THERE HAVE BEEN PROBLEMS,
THE UKRAINIANS NEEDED THAT
ACCESS TO SATELLITE INTERNET.
IT CREATED A BULWARK AGAINST
RUSSIA'S CYBERATTACKS.
IN THE CASE OF, YOU KNOW,
LAUNCHES THROUGH NASA, WE ARE
NOW NO LONGER RELIANT ON THE
RUSSIANS TO DO THAT.
NASA OFFICIALS TOLD ME WE ARE
MOVING FASTER IN SOME OF THESE
CASES.
>> THE TWITTER THING IS
DIFFERENT.
>> BUT THE TWITTER THING IS
DIFFERENT, RIGHT.
AND WE ARE SEEING IN THESE
RECENT YEARS THAT ELON MUSK HAS
BEHAVED ERRATICALLY AT TIMES,
THAT THE BIOGRAPHICAL FACTS THAT
YOU MENTIONED THAT LED TO HIM AT
TIMES TALKING ABOUT HIS
LONELINESS, SADNESS, THE FACT
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN QUESTIONS
ABOUT HIS PSYCHO PHARMACOLOGY
AND REPORTS ABOUT THE TESLA
BOARD BEING WORRIED ABOUT HIS
KETAMINE USE, THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT CAN BE USED IN A
LEGAL AND HEALTHY WAY.
HOWEVER, THERE IS CONCERN, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS A HUMAN BEING THAT
WE ARE GIVING ALL THIS POWER TO,
AND THERE ARE VERY FEW CHECKS ON
THAT POWER RIGHT NOW.
>> I SHOULD SAY IN THE STORY YOU
SAY THAT YOU REACHED OUT TO ELON
MUSK.
HE DID NOT RESPOND.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY RESPONSE
SINCE ITS BEEN PUBLISHED?
>> HE DECLINED TO ANSWER
QUESTION FORCE THE PIECE, WHICH
IS A SUBTLE BUT SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE FROM NOT RESPONDING.
>> SURE.
>> IT'S HIS PREROGATIVE TO DO
THAT.
THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT ELON
MUSK IS HE HAS BEEN THE SUBJECT
OF SO MANY BOOKS, BIOGRAPHIES,
PROFILES AND HE IS A RARE CASE
LIKE THE MYSTERY IS NOT HIM.
HE IS ENGAGED IN A STREAM OF
CONSCIOUSNESS, YOU KNOW, A
MONOL
MONOLOGUE ABOUT HIMSELF THROUGH
A HUGE SWATH OF PUBLIC LIFE.
HE IS TWEETING, X'ING, I GUESS
WE WOULD SAY, ALL THE TIME.
WE KNOW A LOT ABOUT HIM.
AND I FELT LIKE WHAT WE WEREN'T
HEARING WAS WHAT IS IT LIKE FOR
THE PEOPLE OR THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE TABLE FROM HIM IN ALL THESE
SECTORS.
>> THIS IS A BRILLIANT FRAMING
BECAUSE WE DON'T OFTEN TALK
ABOUT WHAT HE MEANS FOR US.
WHAT HE MEANS FOR SOCIETY AND
THE WORLD AND AMERICA.
AND WHAT DID YOU -- YOU SAID THE
PRIVATE POWER, IS THE WORD YOU
USED.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
>> YEAH.
I APPRECIATE YOU ALL HAVING A
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION ABOUT
THAT.
IT'S HEADY TO GET INTO
HISTORICAL ECONOMIC POLICY ON A
MORNING SHOW LIKE THIS.
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT.
IT RESONATES WITH ALL OF US,
RIGHT?
HOW MUCH POWER WE ARE PUTTING IN
THE HANDS OF PRIVATE PEOPLE,
INDIVIDUALS --
>> WITH NO CHECKS.
>> AND BE DANGEROUS OR ERRATIC
FOR ALL THE GOOD THEY DO.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE WANT TO
THINK AND TALK ABOUT.
THERE IS A QUOTE FROM A FORMER
NASA ADMINISTRATOR, JIM
BRIGHTENSTEIN, A TRUMP
APPOINTEE, YOU KNOW, A
CONSERVATIVE.
VERY ABOUT PROTECTING ECONOMIC
PROGRESS AND NOT EX OUTING
GOVERNMENT POWER.
HE SAYS A POWERFUL THING.
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT TOO
MUCH DEREGULATION CAN ALSO
PRESENT DANGERS AND THAT IF WE
ARE PUTTING OUR EGGS IN ONE
BASKET, THE ELON BASKET, THAT
COULD PRESENT SOME DANGER.
SO THE FACT THAT EVEN
CONSERVATIVES ARE SAYING THAT IN
THIS PIECE IS MEANINGFUL.
>> IT IS A FASCINATING PIECE.
RONAN FARROW, THANK YOU FOR
COMING IN TO TALK WITH US ABOUT